monsieur le nôtre j'ai entendu dire je
ne sais pas si c'est flatteur ou pas
vous appelle un peu le napoléon de la
pâtisserie
[Musique]
pour moi il ya sur le nôtre c'est le
maître donc et c'est vrai que c'est lui
qui a fait évoluer la pâtisserie je
sentais que la le règne de crème au
beurre qui durait depuis un siècle
c'était ça allait se terminer
les packs très lourde sa salle être
complètement il nous fallait plus en bon
on a travaillé donc beaucoup plus 16e ou
deuxième mission de mousse pour pouvoir
réussir à voir ne pas disputer le gère
en consommer autant en tant que volume
est à moitié moins lourd dans le point
et dessert cette coupure apport par le
dessert du jour présent lorsqu'une fait
lorsqu'il ya de la joie de notre rôle à
nous pâtissier c'est de créer et de
participer à toute la joie on est
présent partout mon âme est
extraordinaire
[Musique]
cet homme est passé en trente ans du
stade de simple apprenti à celui de chef
d'entreprises regroupant quelques 400
personnes qualifiées sous sa houlette
experte de pâtissier vous êtes dans le
temple de la gourmandise chez gaston
lenôtre
quelquefois le mercredi le petit mitron
devenu businessman se paye même le luxe
de faire visiter lui même il entrouvre
les portes de son école internationale
au club des jeunes gastronomes
[Musique]